welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of the
ending and post credit scene for 2023's
the flash a truly wild Multiverse event
adapting the 2011 Flashpoint comic
storyline that went places I don't think
any of us expected but spoiler rewarding
before I continue I am going to break
down the big twists that come up in this
movie's final minutes and what it all
means and please support this growing
Network by subscribing to this channel
subscribing to my deep dive channel for
our Spielberg summer slate and to the
break room for instant reactions to all
this great stuff and you can support us
with an indie I love you shirt at
nerdriot.shop okay so the 2023 Flash
movie tells the story of our universe's
Barry Allen played by Ezra Miller
running back in time to save his mother
Nora Allen and to exonerate his father
Henry Allen who is falsely accused for
murdering her this time Vortex is
represented in this movie by what's
called a Chrono Bowl which is a kind of
Coliseum of infinite moments in time
kind of like the Tesseract and
Christopher Nolan's Interstellar put
circular instead of at 90 degree angles
Barry displaces a fateful can of tomato
sauce in a supermarket so that his
mother wouldn't be left alone at home on
the day of her murder as Henry Allen
went back shopping for it interestingly
this movie does oddly come down to
Spaghetti as Michael Keaton Bruce Wayne
later he uses uncooked spaghetti noodles
to explain alternate realities and how
unlike movies like Avengers in game
Branch realities in this movie don't
split off from the normal timeline but
rather when a timeline is ruptured it
skews on a wholly different reality
where history had already been playing
out differently since before you altered
it an example given is the movie Back to
the Future which in this alternate
timeline starred Eric Stoltz as Marty
McFly instead of Michael J fox Eric
Stoltz was the original actor who played
Marty McFly before they restart huge
portions of this movie with Michael J
fox but in this timeline saltz
apparently was never recast this is
actually something I explain in great
detail in my deep dive of Back to the
Future which you should watch along with
my analyzes of Michael Keaton's Batman
and Nolan's Interstellar apparently I've
been just reviewing movies that have
been required viewing for this movie
anyway after altering history and saving
his mother Barry gets shoved in a Chrono
bowl by this dark presence we later
learned dark Flash and Barry skews into
a point in time 10 years prior shortly
before he would have gotten his powers
and so Barry reunites with his alternate
timeline parents and meets his younger
self olderberry takes younger Berry to
the lab to set up the conditions of his
superhero origin but Lightning goes
through oldbury into youngberry giving
young Berry Powers while removing old
Barry's powers and one of old Barry's
teeth that he has to Super Glue back in
which is important because it comes back
later but how Zod arrives following the
events of the 2013 Man of Steel in the
Battle of metropolis the world engine so
they go to Wayne Manor to seek Batman's
help but Batman in this universe is
Michael Keaton he helps the berries
track down Kalel in a siberian prison
but they discover the Kryptonian is
actually kalel's cousin Kara zorel they
all Escape Barry and Bruce try to
restore Barry's Powers but it fails and
Cara flies him up to get zapped by
lightning directly and it works now so
the four of them together confront Zod
and Batman kamikazes the Batwing against
zod's shield and he dies and Kara gets
stabbed by Zod because she contains the
genetic codex for all the kryptonians
the two berries return to the Chrono
Bowl to try to play it back again but
Bruce and Kara die again Barry realizes
that this is is a fixed point in time
it's unchangeable but young Barry won't
hear it he tries again and again he gets
impaled with shards of fuselage which
you weaponize against the kryptonians
pretty effective but it increasingly
disfigures him having fallen in love
with Kara he just refuses to let her and
Bruce die so then in the crota ball dark
flash appears and we learn that this
monstrous flash is Young Barry himself
having aged up over countless eons
trying to save Care and Bruce he reveals
that it was he who knocked our berry to
this point in time to originally start
himself on this path so the credible
begins to rupture and then we see that
it's actually one of many differently
colored domes and globes imagery evoking
the infinite Earths of the DC Multiverse
in the comics and here we see a ton ton
of cameos from DC cinematic History
George Reeves Superman from the 50s TV
series Adventures of Superman Jay
Garrick played by Teddy Sears and the CW
Flash series wearing that Crimson Comet
helmet the late Christopher Reeve
Superman recreated with CGI and at aside
Helen Slater DH back to her 1984
Supergirl appearance the late Adam West
Batman and then a sphere with Nicholas
Cage Superman long-haired the same suit
he wore in the famous 90s Tim Burton
wardrobe test for Superman lives
fighting the giant spider now I'm gonna
go more into these and what all of these
mean in the backstory of all of them in
another video but really just the
implication is that all of these past
iterations of DC characters exist
somewhere in this multiversal construct
so then youngberry sacrifices himself to
kill dark Flash and dark flash
dissipates and all these colliding
Spears retract back to their Corners
Barry returns to that Supermarket to let
Nora Allen die by moving the can back in
place he has a meaningful goodbye but he
places those tomato cans high enough so
that the security camera will now see
Henry Allen's face when he grabs the can
giving him evidence of Alibi to
exonerate Henry at his trial and then
after this trial Barry's phone rings
it's Bruce Wayne but instead of Ben
Affleck in this reality stepping out of
the car it's George Clooney his first
time returning to play Bruce Wayne since
1997's Batman and Robin directed by Joel
Schumacher not everyone's favorite
Batman movie Barry drops his movies one
PG-13 permitted F-bomb who the is
this clooner says Hey Barry Barry
stammers some nonsense and clooner says
what's wrong with you he looks around
and he smiles and then Barry speechless
opens his mouth and that super glued
tooth falls out and so this Flash movie
ends with Barry Allen not back home in
the universe of Ben Affleck Batman but
in a different reality one perhaps
caused by him exonerating this father
power of a single can of crushed
tomatoes now when I'm living my life
puppet myself up with the score of my
favorite movies I want to hear that
music and only that and that's why I
choose to use raycon earbuds raycon
knows that in this economy every
purchase needs to be perfect and they
design their earbuds with that perfect
purchase in mind
fit so good their noise isolating
earbuds have a battery life of up to
eight hours plus easy tap controls that
let you control what you're listening to
without digging your phone out of your
pocket and the sound you get oh so good
raycon small But Mighty team of design
audio Engineers cut their teeth at
Brands like Bose and Peloton if you're
not happy with the purchase raycon has
an easy and free return guarantee but
over 50 000 5 Star reviews suggest you
will be thrilled raycon offers buy now
pay later option to check out and free
domestic shipping or we can ship
internationally for a flat free click
the link in the description box or go to
buy raycon.com new rockstars to get 15
off your raycon purchase now technically
the 1989 Batman 1992 Batman Returns 1995
Batman Forever in 1997 Batman and Robin
are all considered to be from the same
Earth 89 universe but just with Batman
recast for Michael Keaton of Val Kilmer
to George Clooney because many of the
other actors stayed the same it's just
really the production design got crazier
and crazier and notice the production
design here this Courthouse the city
block they just ain't Joel Schumacher
enough to be the same universe as Batman
arrive in 1997. this likely a side
Universe where Bruce Wayne is also
George Clooney just like the side
Universe with younger Barry Allen had
and it's Bruce Wayne as Michael Keaton
so this brings us to the film's
post-credits scene there's just one of
them Barry and Arthur Curry Aquaman
Jason Momoa exit a bar Arthur's drunk
Barry says what I am trying to explain
as simply as I possibly can I promise
they were all Batman they were all Bruce
Wayne but each of them is a completely
different person and Arthur says so in
another lifetime and Barry corrects
timeline and Arthur continues I'm the
same guy and Barry says yeah actually
pretty much you're lovable furry loyal
motivated by bacon Arthur thanks him and
then drunkenly face plants into a puddle
does it need to come back up for air
Barry says he lives right upstairs but
Arthur says Barry I live right here and
he Pats the gutter water yes Sperry for
another beer and gives him one of his
Rings Atlantean treasure Barry walks off
pocketing the ring as Arthur drunkenly
sings I'm a sailor now they explicitly
say that Jason Momoa plays the Aquaman
both in this Clooney verse and back in
the DC EU continuity of Ben Affleck so I
think we can assume that Aquaman in the
lost kingdom won't be this Aquaman who's
drunkenly sucking up gutter water but
rather one from the previous continuity
of the first Aquaman film but still
after all this goofing around we just
have to wonder how seriously they want
us to take these characters going
forward James Gunn indicated this week
that only Blue Beetle will return as
part of his DCU Gods and Monsters plan I
mean the first DCU character for sure is
Blue Beetle in the First full DC move
DCU movie is Superman I think the
infinite Earth's moment with the
colliding Chrono balls was meant to
convey the DC equivalent of an incursion
and some characters may have been left
and altered universes because some of
those fears smushed into each other in
fact one of those incursions could have
coincided with Ezra Miller Barry Allen's
Cameo and the CW crisis on infinite
Earth's event in 2020. so while this
version of The Flash may not be in the
DCU James Gunn continues to build from
here forward he's still out there in the
Multiverse somewhere and based on this
geography not that far away and with the
handsomest Batman but I want to know
from you how do you feel about the way
this movie ended subscribe to the Deep
dive Channel and the break room and
support us by grabbing some merch at
nerdright.shop you can follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at EA boss follow
new Rockstar subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
thank you